current farming practices the
conventional agrochemical is
contributing significantly to the
impacts of climate change one of the
great aspects of being a soil biology
consultant is that we want to be able to
help our clients deal with the impacts
of climate change but then also change
their farming practices so they're no
longer contributing to helping reverse
climate change and making those Farmers
much more resilient and ultimately
providing a much more healthy nutritious
product for the people who are consuming
food
[Music]
in order to become a soil biology
consultant there is a certified
Consultants training program there's a
lot of continuing education that's
involved in this type of work there's a
tremendous amount of Sciences coming out
about the role of soil biology soil
Health plant Health how do we actually
take those discoveries and apply them
practically to our clients and our
farmers
some of my clients I'll interact with
them once or twice per year other my
clients I'll interact with them all
throughout the entire growing season it
does fluctuate but really I carry about
15 active clients at a time we are on
our way to go visit Kwame and Jake at
Morris Roots Farm which is a farm that
is north of Portland and just south of
Washington state my role is to look at
the techniques that they use and
determine
is it harmful to the soil biology is it
beneficial or is it neutral and the way
I really look at this with my clients
it's a partnership
so what I know about Kwame and Jake's
operation is that they're already you
know fairly far ahead of the game as far
as trying to develop a regenerative
organic farm so I'll learn a lot more
when I actually get on site
[Music]
we'll take some soil samples and we'll
Baseline and say okay this is where our
starting point is and then now let's try
to incorporate some of these tools or
techniques to try to increase the
biology I'm relying on the natural okay
plant tell me sometimes the plants won't
tell you they're stressed early on early
on and then also you know by the time
they get stressed
okay I got challenges yeah
I'll collect soil samples take
compaction measurements water filtration
I want to take it halfway in the drip
line and if you've never heard the term
before drip line all that means is the
outer edge of the leaf makes a line and
that was what we call the drip line so
halfway between the outer edges of the
leaf to the stem is where you want to
collect your soil sample that's where
you're going to have kind of an average
amount of roots growing in the system so
take your fingers down here pop yourself
a little hole perfect
they're fantastic good deal
foreign
[Music]
microscope and then let you know
when we take a soil sample we will do
what we call a biological assessment of
that soil what we're using is a
microscope to identify organisms like
bacteria and fungi and protozoa and
nematodes and then understanding those
populations of organisms tells us a lot
about the condition of the soil and is
it optimal for the plants that we're
trying to grow
I get asked a question from a lot of
folks that are looking to get into this
type of work can I make a living wage
and my answer to them is yes the need
and the opportunity space to be able to
do this work is tremendous and there's
so few of us that are actually doing
this work that having access to clients
is not an issue there is going to be a
massive transition away from
agrochemical to farming with Biology it
just makes sense we know we can do it as
more Farmers actually make the
transition from their typical
agrochemical or traditional organic to
farming with soil biology their
successes are going to drive other
Farmers into wanting to apply these
practices
and it's making me look good yeah